santé
avec une surface de plus de 10 000
mètres carrés se data center s'inscrit
dans la continuité de la souveraineté
européenne télé-house la inauguré à
Magny-les-Hameaux ce lundi 2 octobre en
présence du ministre de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications nous
avons là un centre de données qui va
être destiné en priorité aux acteurs
souverains d'associés
nous avons un territoire qui est très
numérique et très fortement marqué par
la souveraineté numérique si vous le
végétal absence de gaz frigorigènes le
data center se veut éco-responsable en
mettant en place des actions concrètes
pour réduire ses émissions de gaz quand
on aimait du CO2 c'est notre
responsabilité de tendre vers le réduire
et c'est le cas pour les Data Center qui
consomme beaucoup d'énergie qui
consomment beaucoup d'électricité donc
notre responsabilité c'est de prendre ce
sujet à bras le corps et mettre des
actions concrètes qui permettent
d'arriver à 0 CO2 pour cette activité ce
que l'essence même du numérique c'est
décarbonée l'économie c'est-à-dire que
de réduire les flux physique qui assure
terre et de les passer sur le numérique
qui devient décarbonée donc pour faire
ça on a une obligation et on essaie de
remplir cette obligation en voulant
contribuer à un avenir plus durable télé
house engage à atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2026